the golf GTE is the first plug-in hybrid
from Volkswagen like the GTI and GTD
models it's powerful fast and sporty it
has a broad stance with up to 18 inch
wheels that give it a firm grip on the
road but why GTE it's simple
it connects two worlds a conventional
gasoline internal combustion engine with
an electric motor which is where the e
comes from our tester Klaus needs fit
says drivers have come to expect pure
sportiness from the GTI not least thanks
to the chassis construction and they
won't be disappointed with the GTE
bhatia Amanda the electric motor
supplements the TSI gasoline engine
making the GTE particularly efficient
its sporty side can be activated by
pressing a button the TSI and the e
motor joined forces to give the GTE full
performance with 150 kilowatts and 350
Newton meters of torque and extend the
rates from 0 to 100 km/h in 7.6 seconds
despite this VW claims fuel consumption
is only 1.5 litres per 100 kilometers
Klaus says that's another benefit to
driving a golf GTE it's very cheap to
run driving 50 kilometers on electric
power costs only around 1 euro and 80
cents less than half as much as with a
gasoline engine and when the driver hits
the brakes the e motor becomes a
generator turning motion back into
electric power it's a process known as
recuperative braking and the energy
recovered in this way can be used later
to power driving this means the GTE
saves on gasoline but not on sportiness
but why does the plug-in hybrid only
have a maximum range of 50 kilometres in
purely electric mode PWAs Heights Jakob
noiser says the firm deliberately
limited this range for the urban
environment 50 kilometers is more than
enough to meet the daily driving needs
of most city dwellers under the hood the
two hearts of the GTE beat as one
electric and gasoline power the electric
motor sits between the TSI engine and
the dual clutch transmission a
high-voltage battery stores the
electrical energy as a hybrid the GTE
uses mostly electric traction and city
traffic and the push of a button makes
it a completely electric car but even
then it's no slouch in e mode the GTE
can reach 130 km/h the centre console
provides information about energy flow
power and range with the GT e--'s
electric motor and efficient 1.4 liter
TSI it can cover distances of up to nine
hundred forty kilometres on a full tank
while they'd be down Klaus svw offers
very different Drive concepts for its
car models there are diesel and gasoline
engines there is natural gas CNG ethanol
and all-electric traction but right now
this plug-in hybrid is most interesting
as a sign of things to come
what's also interesting is that VW can
build this golf on an assembly line and
can install the drivetrain its customers
request here in Wolfsburg the Gulf
production line is bumper-to-bumper the
show remains always the same but what's
under the hood can be very different the
GTE can be identified by its orange
cables this means VW can always respond
flexibly to the needs and desires of its
customers where other manufacturers have
set up entire plants to cater to
electrical mobility Wolfsburg has tried
to keep things simple and so it makes no
difference for the workers if they're
producing the Eagle natural gas golf
gasoline diesel ethanol GTI GTD or even
this latest GTE
you still know sir says the GTE is first
being sold in Europe but it's a concept
that's also ideal for the world's other
markets a car like this is ideal for
places where the recharging
infrastructure for battery operated
vehicles is not as widely available
because it can fill up with regular
gasoline which is available everywhere
so there's no risk of running out of
power a survival food buyers
tobita same decision right the mobility
as a plugin the GTE is charged with a
standard socket using alternating
current from a standard home outlet that
takes less than four hours and with a
special wall box power socket only a
little over two hours
otherwise the GTE is outwardly no
different from its siblings except for
its badge and blue trim even from behind
it has the familiar look of a VW Golf
and again only the badge gives it away
emission-free II Drive sporty hybrid and
efficient TSI things many more cars may
offer in future that the GTE offers now
what does our tester think my thoughts
it he says the golf GTE is a great
sports car and good for the environment
as well as being cheap to run on the
other hand it costs at least thirty six
thousand nine hundred euros but is very
well-equipped but for this price
you get a really great car Abha foodies
and pies Hickman oh I'm victory tall as
Otto